[موسيقى]
مساء الخير لا يمكن لاحد ان يفهم سياسه
فضلا عن ان يدخل عالمها دون ان يفهم
كلمتين اساسيتين
اليسار واليمين فهمك لليسار واليمين يمهد
الطريق لفهم كلمات اخرى مفتاحيه مثل محافظ
والبرالي وقومي وغيرهم واسهل مدخل لفهم
مفهوم اليمام اليمين واليسار اللي سالتوني
عليهم كثيرا قبل ذلك وحانوا موعد الوفاء
بالوعد هو ان نعود لبدايه القصه واللحظه
التي ولدت فيها هذه الكلمات بشكل تلقائي
جذور اليمين واليسار بتعود للايام الاولى
للثوره الفرنسيه اللي اندلعت في صيف
بعد الثوره اجتمع اعضاء البرلمان الفرنسي
او ما يسمى بالجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه
لوضع دستور جديد يعبر عن فرنسا بعد الثوره
وكانت احد اهم القضايا الرئيسيه التي بدا
الاعضاء في مناقشتها هو مقدار السلطه التي
يجب ان يتمتع بها الملك
هل سوف يظل يتمتع بسلطات مطلقه كما كان
قبل الثوره ام تقل الصلاحياته احتدم
النقاش وانقسم النواب
جلس بشكل تلقائي اولئك الذين اعتقدوا ان
المالك يجب ان يتمتع بصلاحيات مطلقه مع
بعضهم على يمين رئيس المجلس وجلس الذين
عارضوهم بشكل تلقائي على يسار رئيس المجلس
اي ان الراغبين في الحفاظ على النظام
والقوانين والعادات والاوضاع التي كانت
قائمه من مئات السنين جلسوا على اليمين
واولئك الذين ارادوا التغيير والتحرر من
الاوضاع القديمه كانوا على اليسار ومنذ
ذلك الوقت بدات كلمه اليمين تشير الى
المحافظين واليسار يشير الى الثوريين او
الليبراليين ومن هنا ولد مفهوم اليمين
واليسار ومعهما كلمتين محافظ الايطالي
مع الوقت اصبحت افكاري اليسار واليمين
واضحه اليسار بصفه عامه مشغول بفكرتين
اساسيتين في اي مكان في العالم الفكره
الاولى هي العداله الاجتماعيه والفكره
الثانيه هي الدفاع عن الحريات الفرديه
يسعون يعني اليسار تسعى الاحزاب اليساريه
لتحقيق العداله الاجتماعيه من خلال الدوله
اي تلعب الحكومه عند اليسار دورا اكبر في
تنظيم حركه المجتمع بحيث لا ياكل القوي
الضعيف ما يعني انهم في حاجه لحكومه كبيره
كلمه حكومه كبيره خطا لانها جزء من الجدل
بين اليسار واليمين حكومه كبيره يعني جهاز
بروقراطي ضخم ينظم كل انشطه الحياه تقريبا
هذه الحكومه الكبيره في العاده تحت حكم
نظام يساري بتفرض ضرائب تصاعديه اي تفرض
ضرائب اعلى كلما زاد دخلك وتنفق هذه
الاموال التي تاتي من الاغنياء او الشرائح
القادره لتنفقها على الشرائح الاقل دخلا
تنفقها في ايه تنفقها على برامج رعايه
صحيه واجتماعيه كبيره يعني معاشات صحي
وتعليم اساسي مجاني ولا باس من وجود
نقابات تدافع عن حقوق العمال هذا عن البند
الاول اللي بيشغل اليسار في العالم وهي
العداله الاجتماعيه الامر الثاني اللي
بيشغل اليسار هي الحريات الخاصه اليسار
بيسعى طوال الوقت لحمايه الحريات الخاصه
بحيث لا يتغول المجتمع او الدوله على حقوق
الفرد ولذلك يقترن كلمه اليسار بكلمه
ليبرالي اليسار الليبرالي فمثلا يدافعون
عن حقوق المثليين وحقوق كل الاقليات
ويرحبون بالمهاجرين وحق المراه في الاجهاض
وبديه انهم يدافعون عن العولمه اي حريه
انتقال العماله والافكار ورؤوس الاموال
انا انسان وكل بلاد العالم اوطاني اليمين
العكس
اليمين غير مشغول بفكره الحريات الخاصه
على النحو اللي بيتحدث عنها اليسار وانما
بالنظام والقانون لهون اوردر اي محاوله
الحفاظ على تقاليد المجتمع واستقراره
ولذلك يقترن اليمين بكلمه محافظ اليمين
المحافظ اليمين ايضا غير مشغول كثير بفكره
العداله الاجتماعيه بشكلها الواسع عند
اليسار فقط مشغول بتطبيق القانون وحمايه
الفئات الاكثر احتياجا او ضعفا في اي
مجتمعه ببساطه لان اليمين يرى ان المساواه
ليست ممكنه والتسلسل العربي في اي مجتمع
امر حتمي وطبيعي في اي جماعه انسانيه في
العالم اذا تركت لحالها يكون في اغنياء
وفقراء حاكمين ومحكومين مسيطرين ومسيطر
عليهم ولذلك يسعون لاطلاق اليات السوق
باقل قدر من التدخل من السلطه ويفضلون
حكومه صغيره تطبيقا للقاعده الراسماليه
الشهيره دعه يعمل دعه يمر انا مش محتاج
جهاز بروقراطي ينظم لي كل انشطه الحياه
انا محتاج بس ان الدوله تضع قواعد شفافه
وتطلق حريه السوق والسوق هيتولى امر
المجتمع وتنظيمه
اذا اليسار عاده بيركز على عداله اجتماعيه
تقتضي التدخل من جانب الدوله في ضبط
الاسواق وبيركز على حريات فرديه كبيره
تقتدي ايضا عدم تدخل الدوله في حريه
الافراد لكن اليمين بيركز على اطلاق اليات
السوق باقل قدر من التدخل من جانب السلطه
وبيركز على فرض وتطبيق النظام والقانون
والحفاظ على الاوضاع القائمه
ولذلك اليسار يميل الى الاشتراكيه
باشكالها المختلفه فيما يتبنى اليمين
النظام
الراسمالي او نظام السوق الحر تعالوا ناخذ
امثله عمليه توضح لنا الفروق العامه بين
اليمين واليسار في اي مكان في العالم
المثال الاول الموقف من الهجره
بصفه عامه اليسار بيدعم الهجره والمهاجرين
ليه لانه بيؤمن بالمساواه وبيدافع عن
الحريات وبالضروره يدافع عن حقوق الاقليات
حزب الديمقراطي في الولايات المتحده
كامثال يعتمد على اصوات الاقليات واداره
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن هي كوكتيل من
المهاجرين اما اليمين فهو لا يرحب عاده
بالمهاجرين الا في اضيق نطاق وللضروره
والهدف الحفاظ على
ثقافه المجتمع وهويته
باعتبارهم باعتبارهم طيارا محافظا بيحافظ
على ماذا بيحافظ على ثقافه المجتمع وهويته
وعدم تهديد الاغلبيه العرقيه ودينها
ولغتها في بلد ما الكثير من المهاجرين
هيؤثر سلبا على نقاء المجتمع المتجانس كما
يفضله اليمين المحافظ ولذلك مثلا
يتشدد كل قاده الاحزاب اليمينيه في اوروبا
ضد المهاجرين اخرهم ولوني مثلا ميلوني
اللي هي رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا وهي من
اليمين القومي المتشدد هي
اولوياتها الاولى اغلاق محابس الهجره على
الاقل الهجره غير الشرعيه الى بلادها
واغلاق ايضا الهجره القواعد الهجره
الشرعيه الا لضروره قصوى بحيث تضيف
لايطاليا ولا تنتقص او تؤثر على ثقافتها
وهويتها المثال الثاني هو ملف الحريه
الخاصه اليسار دائما في كل مكان بيدعم
الحريات الخاصه ويدافع عنها ادل الامثله
كثيره حقوق المراه بصفه عامه حقها في
الاجهاض اللي هو دايما مثير للجدل يعني
تتخلص من الجنين ام لا
حقوق زواج المثليين الحق في التحول الجنسي
هو بيدعم كل هذه الحقوق في الغالب لانه
يرفض القيود على حريه الافراد ويدعم حريه
الاختيار اما اليمين فيرفض اطلاق الحق في
الاجهاض ويرفض زواج المثليين لانه
يتعارضوا مع الدين والتقاليد ويهدد
استقرار المجتمع وتقاليده ملحوظه مهمه جدا
لما بقول اليسار بيدعم واليمين بيد انا
بتكلم بصفه عامه انت ممكن هتجد اليمين في
كتل اخرى في دول اخرى يمين النعم ولكنه
ممكن يقبل مثلا بزواج المثليين لان ده
بالنسبه لليمين ثقافه مجتمعه وترهل تهدد
ثقافه المجتمع واصبح شائع كما في بعض
الاحزاب اليمينيه في امريكا او في اوروبا
او بعض القوى اليمنيه في امريكا واوروبا
وممكن تجد يسار زي اليسار اللي موجود في
العالم الاسلامي او العربي يعارض تماما
حقوق الزواج المثليين مثلا او التحول
الجنسي هي عمليه نسبيه بس انا بقول بصفه
عامه غالبا اليسار سوف يفكر هكذا وغالبا
اليمين سوف يفكر هكذا وافتحوا قوسين مع
مراعاه فروق الثقافه
المثال الثالث اللي يوضح بشكل جالي الفرق
بين اليسار واليمين هو الموقف من مفهوم
القوميه هناك يسار قومي وهناك يمين قومي
لكن الفرق في مفهوم القوميه لدى الطيارين
شاسع جدا اليمين قومي بمعنى انه يؤمن
بنقاء عرق او جماعه انسانيه معينه تمييزا
لها عن غيرها واحيانا يدفعه ذلك للدخول في
صراعات مع الجماعات العرقيه الاخرى مثال
مش مثال ده امثله كثيره لكن اختصارا للوقت
هتلر وقناعته بتفوق العرق الالماني وضروره
الحفاظ على رقائه مثال على اليمين القومي
المتطرف اما اليسار القومي فهو قومي بمعنى
انه يسعى لدعم حركات التحرر الوطني من
الاحتلال وهيمنه القوى الاستعماريه عبد
الناصر كان يحسب على هذا التيار فدى
الكاسترو
زعيم كوبا جيفارا
الثوري اليساري الشهير اللي جابه دول
كثيره حول العالم دعم لحركات التحرر
المثال الرابع هو الموقف من الدين اليمين
واليسار كلاهما في الدول الديمقراطيه وتحت
كلمه الديمقراطيه او الغرب الليبرالي
والدول اللي على شكلته مثل اليابان مثلا
اليسار واليمين علمانيون ليس فيهم من يدعو
لحكم ديني ولكن اليسار الليبرالي اي
المتحرر هو تقليديا ضد او عاده لا يتحمس
كثيرا للمؤسسات الدينيه ممكن هو يكون
يساري ومتدين لكن عنده مشكله مع المؤسسات
الدينيه بمعنى انه لا يريد ان يكون الدين
ومؤسساته قيدا على حريه الافراد عاوز
تتدين يبقى ده اختيارك لكن لا يفرض عليك
الدين مثلا يرى انه لا يمكن السماح بزواج
المثليين وهم يرون ان هذه حريه خاصه يجب
احترامها بقطع النظر عن راي الدين لكن
اليساريين وهذه هي المفارقه يذهبون بعيدًا
جدا في الدفاع عن الحقوق الدينيه للانسان
باعتبارها جزءا من الحريات الخاصه وليس
لمجرد انها دين الحريه الدينيه دي بقى ان
انت تتدين في انك تكون مسلم تكون مسيحي
تكون لا ديني هو بيدافع عن قناعاتك
الدينيه ومستعد ان يذهب بعيدا في هذا
الدفاع اما اليمين اليمين المحافظ بطبيعته
فهم يؤمنون ان الدين اي دين يجب ان يلعب
دورا اكبر في المجتمع ويترتب على ذلك رفض
كل التشريعات التي تخالف العادات وروح
الدين مثل الاجهاض كما قلت لحضراتكم حتى
لو كان في ذلك مصادره لحق المراه في
اختيار استمرارها في الحمل ام لا
بيتكلموا على الدين والوطن او الهويه
والعائله
الملحوظه الثانيه احترس من كلمه ليبرالي
لان لها معاني كثيره كلمه ليبرالي مشكله
فعلا لان تعريفها بيختلف من بلد الى بلد
ومن فتره زمنيه الى فتره زمنيه اخرى وهذه
قصه طويله جدا
ومع ذلك الوضع الحالي والشائع ان ممكن
يكون اليسار الليبرالي وممكن يكون اليمين
ليبرالي ولكن بمعنيين مختلفين اليسار
ليبرالي اساسا بمعنى انه يسعى للتحرر من
قيود السلطه والمجتمع على حريات الافراد
وبياس على تحقيق المساواه في الدخل وزياده
معدلات الضرائب على الاثرياء وزياده
الانفاق الحكومي على البرامج الاجتماعيه
لذلك يعتقد اليسار ان المجتمع سيستفيد من
دور حكومه موسعه اليمين ليبرالي بمعنى
مختلف تماما انه هو ليبرالي بمعنى انه
يريد تحرير الاقتصاد واطلاق قوى السوق
بالحد من دور الدوله ولذلك تنتوي سياسات
الاقتصاديه على ضرائب منخفضه على الاثرياء
بصفه رئيسيه عشان يسمح لهم ان هم يتوسعوا
في النشاط الاقتصادي ويوظفه اكبر عدد ممكن
من
الفقراء او من باقي افراد المجتمع
وتنطوي السياساتهم على قليل من التنظيم
على حركه الشركات من قبل الحكومه لذلك
يؤمن اليمين بان حكومه مصغره افضل للمجتمع
الجهاز برقرتي اصغر هيكون افضل لان
الحكومه لا تسيطر ولا يجب ان تسيطر على
النشاط الاقتصادي يعني باختصار ودي نقطه
مهمه جدا ان اليسار بيدافع ويطالب ويريد
حريات خاصه على المستوى الاجتماعي لكنه
يعارض الحريات المطلقه في الاقتصاد اليمين
يعارض الحريات المطلقه اجتماعيا لكنه
يطالب بحريات شبه مطلقه لاليات السوق
الملحوظه الثالثه كل اللي انا قلته من اول
الحلقه هي اطرمه
لمفهوم اليدين واليسار لكن مفهوم اليمين
واليسار بيختلف من ثقافه الى اخرى ودي
نقطه مهمه جدا على سبيل المثال
اليسار في الاتحاد السوفيتي منذ تاسيسه في
العشرينات من القرن الماضي وحتى سقوطه في
نهايه 1991 كان بيتبنى الشيوعيه
مفهوم اليسار عند او في داخل الاتحاد
السوفيتي بيختلف تماما عن اليسار داخل
اوروبا اللي ما زال نشط وحي وبيحكم دول
راس ماليه اليسار في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
كان بيهدف لتذويب الفروق الطبقيه في مقابل
اليمين في الغرب الراسمالي اللي بيؤمن بان
الطبقات والتسلسل الحرمي امر طبيعي وكان
بيركز على فكره ملكيه الدوله الادوات
الانتاج كل المصانع وكل الشركات كل
المزارع تكون مملوكه للدوله وليس للافراد
في مقابل الملكيه الفرديه اللي احنا
عارفينها دلوقتي ان الافراد يمتلكوا
وينتجوا وان الدوله في النظام الراسماليه
يتقلص دورها الى حد ان هي لا تملك شيئا
فقد تنظم حركات النشاط
اليسار في الاتحاد السوفيتي كان بيركز على
التخطيط المركزي للنشاط الاقتصادي
خطه عشريه
المعنى الاساسي اللي بينصرف الى الذهن هو
مفهوم الامن
اليمين في اسرائيل معناها القوى المتشدده
تجاه
من يمثل خطرا على اسرائيل اللي هم طبعا
الفلسطينيين والعرب بصفه خاصه لما تقول
اليسار تشير الى القوى اللي هي مستعد ان
هي تتفاوض مع الفلسطينيين ومع العرب وان
تمنحهم حقوقهم على الاقل على الورق
فاليمين هو من يتشدد
ويتصلب في مواجهه الفلسطينيين ويعلي مفهوم
الامن لليهود اما اليسار فهو اللي بيفضل
مفهوم المفاوضات مع العرب ومع الفلسطينيين
مثال ثالث اهم هناك فرق مثلا احنا عندنا
يمين ديني في الغرب وعندنا هي مين في
العالم الاسلامي او بلاش يمين ديني عشان
يعني هتتكلم عن الفرق بين اليمين الديني
واليمين القومي بعد قليل لكن
في فرق بين اليمين مثلا في الغرب واليمين
في العالم الاسلامي في الغرب اليمين يريد
احترام مضمون وروح الاديان اي دين بشكل
نسبي باعتبار الدين جزء من الثقافه
والهويه ليس اكثر يعني لما مثلا
الرئيس ترامب طوال الوقت بيتكلم على ضروره
احترام المسيحيه مش لانه هو متدين وبيذهب
الى الصلاه ويعني ويعني كل يوم ومتدين لا
ابدا ولكن بالنسبه له المسيحيه كده جزء من
ثقافته كامريكي غربي في مقابل الاديان
الاخرى والثقافات الاخرى
لكن الاحزاب اليمينيه وطبعا الاحزاب
اليمنيه في الغرب كله في امريكا اوروبا هي
احزاب يعني علمانيه بامتياز لا تسمح ابدا
باي حكم ديني لكن اليمين الديني في العالم
الاسلامي يمكن ان تذهب الى الدعوه الى
الحكم من خلال القران والسنه وبالتالي
بتكون معاديه للعلمانيه بكل اشكالها
باشكالها وتدعو لحكم ديني لكن اذا تاملت
الافكار هتجد انه يعني الفرق في الدرجه
صحيح ان الفرق في الدرجه شاسع لكن في
الغرب هو بيدعو لدور اكبر للدين في يعني
في التشريعات
في اداره حركه المجتمع روح الدين اما في
الشرق الاوسط او في العالم الاسلامي
بالنسبه لبعض الاحزاب اليمنيه الدوله هي
الدين والدين هو الدوله وبهذا المعنى لا
يمكن اليمين اللي موجود في يعني ينسجم مع
اليمين اللي موجود في العالم الاسلامي ولا
العكس
ملحوظه رقم اربعه داخل كل ثقافه هناك
درجات لليسار ولليمين يعني هناك اليسار
ويسار الوسط واقسى اليسار اللي بيسمى
احيانا باليسار المتطرف وهناك اليمين
ويميل الوسط واقسى اليمين الذي يسمى
احيانا باليمين المتطرف وهذه كلها تعريفات
سائله مرنه وتختلف من ثقافه لاخرى وسوف
اعطيكم عده امثله لكن قبل ما اديكم امثله
من المهم ان انا اقول لحضراتكم او اذكركم
ان وصف كلمه متطرف ما فيش حد بيقوله على
نفسه ما حدش بيقول انا من حزبي كذا
اليساري المتطرف او انا من حزب كذا
اليميني المتطرف هذه صفه يعني يطلقها
اعدائهم عليهم لكن هم ما بيقولوش على
انفسهم ان احنا يمين او يسار متطرف
مثال الاولاني ان في اوروبا مثلا من يؤمن
بالضرائب باهميه فرد الضرائب التصاعديه
وزياده الانفاق الحكومي على الخدمات
الاساسيه هذا يساري لكن اللي بيؤمن به
الاشتراكيه او ان الدوله تتملك بعض ادوات
الانتاج عشان تحقق استقرار السوء هذا يمثل
اقصى اليسار اما من يؤمن بالشوعيه وافكار
كارل ماركس فهو يساري متطرف فيما ان اللي
بيؤمن بهذه الافكار في الدول الشرعيه اللي
موجوده حتى اليوم زي كوبا زي كوريا
الشماليه زي الصين ليس او لا يعد متطرفا
وهكذا عاوزين تعرفوا الفرق بين الاشتراكيه
والشوعيه استاذنكم وارجعوا الحلقه بعنوان
هل الصين ما زالت شيوعيه وفيها عرض يعني
ملخص واظنوا انه ميسور لافكار كارل ماركس
والفرق بين الشيوعيه
والاشتراكيه وطبعا الراسماليه عموما اليوم
لما بنقول يمين متطرف عاده نشير الى اح او
اشخاص ذوي ميول قوميه متطرفه او معادله
للمهاجرين والثقافات الاخرى عندك بن غفير
السياسي الاسرائيلي اللي عاوز بيقول ان
اسرائيل هي فقط لليهود ويسعى لطرد العرب
ده مثال على اليمين المتطرف يعني مثال
صارخ وعندما نقول يسار متطرف بنشير الى من
يؤمن الان بالشيوعيه ومن يدعو الى نزع
الملكيه الفرديه واحيانا نصف من هم
مستعدين للحرب من اجل تحرير الشعوب من اي
قوى استعماريه او مهيمنه زي جيفارا مثلا
في الخمسينات والستينات بانهم
يسار متطرف احيانا اليسار المتطرف ده
مستعد للاستخدام العنف لمقاومه تسلط
الدوله على مواطنيها مؤخرا مثلا الاثار
المتطرف بيشكل او من يوصف بانه يسار متطرف
هم مش شايفين انفسهم متطرفين هم شايفين
انفسهم جامعات ثوريه تحرريه اليسار
المتطرف ده من وجهه نظر البعض شكل جماعات
عنيفه للدفاع عن حقوق البيئه
شكل جماعات بتستخدم التظاهر العنيف ضد
الاثرياء مستعدين لشن حروب بسبب رغبتهم
اذا وصلوا الى السلطه يعني في فرض اجندات
حقوق الانسان والحريات الخاصه
والتيار اللي بيسمى اليسار التقدمي داخل
الحزب الديمقراطي في امريكا مثال على ذلك
اما اليمين المتطرف فمستعد لخوض حروب
وتدبير مؤامرات لتغيير الانظمه الحكم
دفاعا على الاقتصاد
المفتوح والسوق الحر والحزب الجمهوري في
امريكا مثال على ذلك وطبعا في قوه قوميه
في قوى يمنيه قوميه مستعده متطرفه مستعده
ان تخوض حروبا كرها في قوميات اخرى تعتقد
انها تمثل خطرا عليها
وحروب يوغسلافيا في التسعينات فيها اكثر
من مثال على ذلك
من اقصى اليمين واقصى اليسار هناك يسار
الوسط او يمين الوسط ده معناه ايه طبعا دي
قصه طويله لكن معناه ببساطه يعني ان في
شخص او حزب برجماتي عملي وليس مش متصلب
فيه اراء وقناعاته مستعد يتبنى ما يراه
مناسبا بقطع النظر عن القناعات الثابته
ابحث عن احزاب الوسط في اوروبا وستجد
امثله لا تقع تحت حصر لاحزاب الوسط وفي
الغالب لما يقول لك انا يسار وسط يعني
يسار وسط او يمين وسط يمين وسط معناه ان
عندك افكار اليمين لكن ممكن تاخد بعض
افكار اليسار يسار وسط ان انت يا ساري لكن
ممكن تاخذ بعض افكار اليمين
فاضل الملحوظه الخامسه والاخيره اين منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والعالم الاسلامي من مفهوم
اليمين واليسار
بدايه الحديث عن اليمين واليسار خصوصا في
العالم العربي محدود جدا لان الحياه
السياسيه راكده والاحزاب ضعيفه لكن عموما
معظم الاحزاب في الوقت الحالي وفي السنين
الطويله الماضيه العشرين والثلاثين
والاربعين سنه الماضيه في الشرق الاوسط
كله وليس العالم العربي وبعد جيران العالم
العربي والشرق الاوسط هي بتنتمي اما الى
اليمين الديني او الى اليمين القومي مع
يعني وجود ضعيف جدا للاحزاب اليساريه ما
هو الفرق بين اليمين القومي واليمين
الديني ببساطه من يقول ان بلد ما هي حق
العرق معين وليكن العرب الكرد الترك
بيعتبر يمين قومي يعني الاتراك مثلا
الاحزاب التركيه اللي بتتشدد جدا في ان
تركيا يحق للاتراك
وتتشدد جدا في اي جماعه عاوزه تعبر او
ترغب في انها تحظى
بامتيازات اكثر مثل الكرد ده بنسميه مين
قومي
ومن يقول ان هذا البلد حق او يجب ان يمتثل
لقيم دين معين يكون يمين ديني يعني بهذا
المعنى هتلاقي تقريبا كل القوه المؤثره في
الشرق الاوسط هي اما يمين قوي يا امين
ديني
يعني مثلا انت عندك حركه انصاف اللي هي
بيتزعمها عمران خان هي بتمثل الطيار
اليميني بامتياز حزب الحريه والعداله في
تركيا يعني حزب يمينيون بامتياز اللي يقود
في اسرائيل والاحزاب المتالفه معه هي
كوكتيل من الاحزاب اليمينيه
الدينيه والقوميه المتشدده بامتياز حزب
مودي اللي بيحكم الهند من 2014 هو حزب
يميني قومي بامتياز عندك معظم التيارات
المؤثره في ايران بتنتمي الى اليمين
الديني الحركات الاسلاميه الكبيره في
العالم العربي الاخوان وغيرهم هي احزاب
يمين ديني بامتياز يعني العالم العربي
العالم الاسلامي الشرقي الاوسط هو يمين في
يمين في يمين في السنوات الاخيره لاسباب
يعني كثيره يطول شرحها لكن يبقى السؤال
اللي انا عندي فضول اعرفه من حضراتكم هل
بعد ان يعني وقفت على الملامح الرئيسيه
لليمين واليسار هل انت يمين بافكارك ام
يسار بافكارك ام تميل الى الوسط اتطلع الى
اجاباتكم واسئلتكم اشكركم والى لق